this video is brought to you by
brilliant a problem-solving based
website and app with a hands-on approach
improve your STEM skills while having a
great time learning at brilliant at org
forward slash bar graphics more on them
in a bit he's likely the most famous
engineer in history in 2002 a BBC poll
named Assam bard Kingdom Brunel the
second greatest Briton of all time
seconds only to of course Winston
Churchill the key player in the
industrial revolution Brunel helps turn
Britain into a global powerhouse under
his guidance railway tracks were laid
across England and Wales at a phenomenal
rate gravity-defying bridges were built
and the first modern ships were
engineered with his trademark top hat
and cigar Brunel became an icon of
Britain's early Victorian age a
self-made man propelling his nation
forward through sheer talent and
entrepreneurial spirit alone yet the
life of is simbad Kingdom Brunel is more
than just the tale of a plucky Brit
leading the steam age the child of a
French refugee father Brunel 'he's life
was only made possible by the explosive
events reshaping the continents his
early years were marked by war and his
father's chronic struggle with debt and
yet his talent for engineering still
allowed him to ride the wave of the
Industrial Revolution to Heights that
had never been matched the Elan musk of
his day this is the story of both Brunel
the man and also the technological
explosion that made his name
[Music]
if your mental image of isambard kingdom
brunel is of the quintessential British
Victorian it might come as a shock to
realize that he was actually half French
burnell's father Mark Brunell came from
a religious farming family in Normandy
in fact they were so religious that mark
was originally meant to become a priest
although his talent for numbers
convinced his family to instead let him
train in engineering still the French
Brunel's were mostly about God family
and loyalty to their King and that was a
problem because mark came of age just as
France was deciding that Kings they just
looked better without their heads on
July the 14th 1789 a Parisian mob
stormed the Bastille prison firing the
opening shot of the French Revolution
when revolution broke out mark was
serving abroad in the French army so he
missed most of the early highlights
including the women's march on
Versailles and the Kings attempted
flight of r-n but mark did manage to be
back in Paris just in time for the
summer of 1792 aka just in time for the
Med to really hit the fan on August the
10th 1792 a working class insurrection
engulfed Paris we don't have time to go
into the details here but the absurd is
that it changed the course of the
revolution suddenly cautious non
murderous revolution was out and
guillotines and regicide was very much
in amazingly all this carnage merely
provided a backdrop to Mark's time in
Paris you see 1792 was the summer that
he fell in love
Sophia kingdom was from a British naval
family the youngest of 16 children with
remarkably bad timing a parents had sent
her to Paris that year to practice her
French instead she wound up first
falling in love and then nearly losing
that love to the reign of terror in 1793
marks royalist sympathies forced him to
flee the country just ahead of
Robespierre as goon-squad he bade Sofia
good-by and hightailed it for New York
just one of many refugees fleeing madame
guillotine yes he was a refugee so in
response to that rather strange question
what of refugees ever contributed to
society the odds
oh I don't know maybe the industrial for
a new revolution while lying low in
America mark made some contacts in the
British Navy in 1799 he traveled to
Britain married Sofia Kingdom and
started working on the Portsmouth docks
very developed method for mass producing
rigging blocks something which gave the
Royal Navy a much-needed edge over
Napoleon's fleet at the Battle of
Trafalgar in recognition of his help the
Royal Navy paid marker handsome son
handsome enough for him and Sofia too at
last
settle down and raise a family on April
the 9th 1806 their son was born they
named him Isambard after an alias that
mark sometimes used but it wouldn't be
just his name that isambard kingdom
brunel inherited from his father or his
diminutive stature it would also be a
Mensa level grasp of mathematics it was
mark who instilled in Brunel a love of
the language of engineering an
appreciation of what it took to
construct something from scratch neither
father or son could have known it in
those early years but this love affair
with engineering it was destined to
change the world
[Music]
in 1815 Napoleon's Empire collapsed
ending 26 years of French upheaval as
the monarchy was restored and the threat
of revolution faded mark made two
important decisions the first was that
he would send his son to France to study
maths where the schools were superior
the second was that he was going to do
something to help the troops in the
aftermath of the Napoleonic Wars tens of
thousands of veterans were returning to
Britain but rather than recognize their
valor the government was all like well
thanks a bunch for all of your help and
here is a whole pile of nothing mark was
so shocked by the sight of destitute
shoeless British veterans that he
decided to build a machine for mass
producing boots for them unfortunately
he super ever spends and the government
responded by throwing him in debtors
prison for young isambard kingdom brunel
this was a formative experience his
father was as good a engineer as he
would become and yet here Mark was
languishing in prison because he didn't
understand business it was a mistake
that Brunel swore he would never make
yet even a spell in debtors prison
wasn't enough to keep bark out of the
engineering game in 1825 Mark asked his
son now back in Britain and better
trained than ever to help him on a great
construction project possibly the
greatest that London had ever seen they
were going to tunnel underneath the
Thames at this point in history London
was one of the busiest ports in the
world yet getting goods from its docks
to the south of England was an
unbelievable cluster headache first
merchandise had to be loaded onto
mule-drawn carts then it had to be taken
across London Bridge at a snail's pace
the idea of tunneling under the Thames
to forge an alternative route was not
new but it was truly thought to be
impossible now mark and Brunel were
going to make it happen
construction on the Thames tunnel began
in 1825 and immediately it turned into a
bit of a nightmare
there were leakages ventilation problems
floods not to mention it was also slow
going that it constantly teated on the
verge of financial disaster at one point
money got so low that mark opens it up
to tourists hiring brass bands to play
as people wandered the unfinished tunnel
but while the tunnel was a major
migraine for father and son it would
also be there
making on marks side the difficulties
led him to invent the world's first
tunneling shield concept that is still
in use today on Brunel side the reap to
greatness was just a bit more twisty in
1828 part of the tunnel ceiling
collapsed and the Thames came flooding
in now the Thames may be small by global
River standards but it's still not
something you want to have crashing down
on your head six workers were killed in
the ensuing flood it would have been
even more had Brunel knock-on charging
in to help the miners saving lives in
the process
but while Brunel being here it was great
and all the important part is that his
heroism left him injured indeed he was
so badly injured that he had to
convalesce for a year as marks right
fruitlessly to gather more money to
drain the tunnel and continue digging
Brunel layoffs at home bought out of his
skull it was in this restive state that
something caught the young man's eye the
city of Bristol was holding a design
competition for a bridge crossing the
avon gorge right next to the affluent
suburb of Clifton
so Brunel decided to enter in he won't
be surprised to learn that he'd
definitely won now you're watching video
all about a famous engineer and if you'd
like to improve your skills in that
department well I would definitely
recommend today sponsored brilliant
brilliant is a problem-solving website
and staffed with a hands-on approach
they've got over 60 interactive courses
in maths science and computer science
now you've heard me talk about brilliant
before if you've been watching this
channel regularly they teach you all
about math science computer science but
beyond that they really teach you
problem-solving skills which a practical
even if you don't pursue the sciences
learning how to break down complex
problems to their component parts is
pretty critical in any career path you
choose and indeed you're probably seeing
that in today's video now maybe you've
wanted to learn programming that you've
always been a bit daunted by normally it
requires you to learn the tedious
details of a specific programming
language but really the bedrock of
programming is understanding the
fundamental algorithms and brilliance
you start by programming a drone with
simple instructions which teaches you
the basic structure of every program
that
going to write it's all drag-and-drop
exercises which will get you thinking
like a computer scientist in no time and
that's just one example there's loads of
great stuff look brilliant is a great
compliment to watching educational
videos like this one and it will really
help your master even complex and
technical subjects so if you want to
support this show and get unlimited
access to all of brilliance in-depth
maths and science courses please head
over to brilliant at all /by graphics
and you'll get 20% off their annual
premium subscription and let's get back
to the video today the Clifton
suspension bridge is one of the icons of
Victorian engineering a vast span that's
emblematic of Bristol if you want to
know how it looked during Grinnell's
time though just concentrate very hard
and picture absolutely nothing that's
because like the Thames tunnel the
Clifton suspension bridge was yet
another Brunel project that ran
completely over budget and wound up
getting abandoned but while the Thames
tunnel would become an albatross around
marks knack that dragged him down until
its eventual completion in 1841 the
Clifton bridge had the opposite effect
on Brunel building it resulted in him
being introduced to the great and good
of Bristol and the grating that of
Bristol just so happens to be looking
for someone to build their first railway
so here's something you need to know
about 1830s Britain the country was in
the process of going absolutely railway
mad in the early part of the 19th
century there had been a boom in canal
and Road building as cities started to
connect up but no sooner had most of
Britain bet big on canals than
everything changed in 1829 Robert
Stevenson successfully tested his rocket
effectively the first steam train that
same year the Rockies began running the
line between Liverpool and Manchester
before long the entire north was moving
to the shrill whistle of steam down
south in Bristol a theatre began to grow
that a lack of railway would seem to
moat them from major ports to ourselves
from Hicksville and that was how in 1833
is some bad Kingdom Brunel found himself
contracted by the Great Western Railway
company to build the first line
connecting Bristol to London this was an
incredible project
in mind that Bernal was only 27 with the
Clifton bridge running out of funds and
the Thames tunnel still stalled Brunel
knew this was his chance to make his
mark so he decided he wasn't just going
to build a normal railway line he was
gonna go back and redesign everything
from first principles that meant
designing those same luxury carriages
himself designing the locomotive that
would pull them it also meant designing
iconic stations like London's Paddington
and Bristol's Temple Meads it was a huge
undertaking one that would guarantee
Brunel finally stepped out of marks
shadow it was also very nearly his final
job Brunel may have been an unmatched
genius at designing stuff like
Paddington Station and the Great Western
line itself but he was an absolute
schmuck at designing locomotives in the
late 1830s tests using Brunel engines
were so disastrous that he came this
close to getting his ass fired in the
end though everyone figured that firing
Brunel would be throwing the baby out
with the mediocre locomotives so they
just made him promise to never ever try
engine design ever again and that was
fine by Brunel he already had his sights
set on something much grander than mere
steam trains he was going to get into
shipbuilding
although Brunel married Mary Elizabeth
Horsley in July 1836 she spent most of
their marriage dismissed as a mere
trophy wife there may have been a
fragment of truth to this no matter what
he might say to the contrary Brunel's
fast love wasn't Mary or even their
children it was working on grand
projects in the early days of the Great
Western Railway Brunel announced to the
directors that he had a plan for an
extension to the line we like to imagine
a Board of stuffy old dudes with maybe
monocles asking incredulously
if Brunel meant to build a line all the
way into Wales when Brunel told them he
actually wanted to open a connection to
America we can only hope that a dozen
monocles simultaneously popped out and
dropped into a dozen cups of D Brunel
vision was to build the first steamship
capable of crossing the Atlantic her
feet at the time of thought to be
impossible some bozos had done the
calculations and concluded that any
steamship trying to cross would require
so much fuel that it would become too
heavy to sail but Brunel was certain
that they were wrong and well now now he
was gonna put his money where his mouth
was in 1834 Brunel set about designing
and building his steamer named the SS
Great Western but ship was a wooden hold
paddle steamer not unlike something you
might see making its way down the
Mississippi incredibly Brunel did this
with zero experience shipbuilding but
rather than becoming a planet-sized
catastrophe it became a game-changing
success in 1838 the finished Western
made her maiden voyage to New York just
as Brunel had predicted she didn't run
out of fuel arriving in the Big Apple
with over 200 tons to spare it could
have been the start of a lucrative new
venture for the great Western company
had they focused on building more
westerns they could have cornered that
transatlantic passenger market but
Brunel hadn't built the Western as a
means it built it as a proof-of-concept
the real achievement would be what came
next just one year after the Westons
maiden voyage Brunel got to work on the
SS Great Britain we heard it said that
this was the first modern shed
everything about it was a testament to
the Industrial Revolution from its iron
hull to its pioneering screw propelled
engine it was also big
so big that when Brunel launched to
Britain in July 1843 it was too big to
get out of the Bristol docks it was only
thanks to a record-breaking high tide in
December 1844 that the monster ship was
able to make it out into the ocean
unfortunately she wouldn't spend very
long at sea though on September the 22nd
1846 the captain of the Britain ran
aground on the coast of Ireland possibly
while he was drunk when Brunel visited
the site of the disaster he angrily
exclaims she's lying like a useless
saucepan kicking about on the most
exposed Shore with no more effort or
skill applied to protect the property
than the said saucepan would have
received on the beach at Brighton the
accidents and subsequent salvage
operation bankrupted the Great Western
steamship company while their railway
arm would survive the dream of cornering
the transatlantic market it was over a
rival company swooped in and bought the
salvaged SS Great Britain taking it out
of Brunel hands forever it was the sort
of Titanic failure that would have acted
as a warning to any other great inventor
a warning not to keep overreaching with
mad projects like Don Quixote tilting at
some steam-powered windmill bus did
Brunel take that warning now what do you
think it's a testament to burnell's mad
genius that pretty much everything that
happens to him gave him some idea for an
invention for example in 1843 he tried
to do a magic trick for his children
only to wind up accidentally swallowing
a coin and getting it stuck in his
windpipe so Brunel designed a machine
that would spin him around so fast that
it would shake the coin loose when that
failed it was mark who saved the day by
suggesting strapping Brunel to a board
holding him upside down and shaking him
and with out of the coin finally came
free but even this high-speed spinning
machine would have nothing on the
madness of Brunel's next project in 1844
the Great Western Railway finally
reached the city of Exeter by now Brunel
built track was crawling all over the
West Country into Wales and up from
Bristol into the Midlands but reaching
accessart posed a problem beyond lay the
wild expanse of Dartmoor a place so
hilly that getting normal trains to go
over it would be a challenge but Brunel
being Brunel he decided to try anyway in
Brunell at visited donkey in Ireland
where had seen an atmospheric railway
and no that's not a rail with a really
great atmosphere but a railway that uses
a vacuum sealed tube to propel its
carriages up and impressively steep
gradients it was this that Brunel
decided to build across da wall to be
cleared this was an insane undertaking
the donkey atmospheric railway works but
it ran for just three kilometres by
contrast Brunel was hoping to build one
that extended over 80 kilometers the
technology was simply untested on such a
scale sort of like if the government
announced out of the blue tomorrow that
they were gonna build a Hyperloop
connecting New York and Washington DC
nevertheless Brunel insisted on it
pushing ahead full steam more rather
should that be full vacuum this was
despite protests from Great Western
amazingly burnell's gamble worked well
they did it fast
by early 1848 the first atmospheric
railway operating on a regular timetable
opens between Exeter and Newton Abbot on
good days its trains were capable of
hitting 110 kph and for a moment it
looked like Brunel had really pulled it
off
but no as impressive as they were all of
Brunel's great projects were doomed to
end in failure almost as soon as the
line had opens the assault II Devon C
air started eating away at the leather
lining of the vacuum tubes causing them
to decay when the company try and
resealing them with grease hungry rats
chewed through them further by 18-49 the
atmospheric railway was in such a bad
shape the Brunel himself recommended
scrapping it all together and starting
again with regular track it was a
colossal waste of money on the Brunel
was wholly responsible for yes it was in
the aftermath of this disaster that we
see some of Brunel's greatness always a
moral man Brunel personally paid for the
atmospheric railways failures out of his
own pocket rather than making great West
and pick up the tab once that was done
he didn't give up on his Devon line but
kept right on working on it eventually
extending track all the way into
Cornwall var the breathtaking Royal
Albert bridge big ideas and zany schemes
aside Brunel was a tireless engineer of
the ordinary one who linked up so much
of westerns Middle Britain in his
lifetime that it helps make the nation
an industrial powerhouse while the
railroads of America would be built by
robber barons like Cornelius Vanderbilt
who cheated and swindled Brunel laid
Britain's tracks
never losing sight of his moral compass
as more of Britain vanished beneath its
rail track Brunel began to turn his mind
back to his greatest failure the SS
Great Britain had been ambitious but not
overly so what if the reason it was seen
as such a failure wasn't because Brunel
had aimed too high but rather too low
what if next time he built something
even bigger the results of that craze
thought was the SS Great Eastern the
single biggest shipbuilding project ever
undertaken
Brunel his plan was to build a ship that
could make it all the way from Britain
to India without having to stop and
refuel maybe it could go even further
but Brunel realized that he couldn't
build such a Leviathan alone so he
called in expert ship builder John Scott
Russell to help him in no time at all
though the two ambitious men would grow
to despise one another
work began on the eastern in 1854
London's Isle of Dogs everything about
the project was so vast that it
challenged everything Brunel knew about
engineering for example Brunel figured
out that a headlong launch into the
Thames would be impossible for a ship of
this size so that always have to launch
her sideways unfortunately when the time
came in 1857 the eastern was so heavy
that she distorted the slipway resulting
in the massive ship becoming stuck
halfway just to get the damn thing in
the river Brunel was forced to invent a
battery of hydraulic presses that would
nudge the Easton out of its rut this was
even harder than it sounds by 1857
Brunel was suffering from a kidney
disease a condition that left him in
chronic pain yet finish his hydraulic
press as he did before long the SS Great
Eastern was finally afloat the biggest
ship in human history the record she
held for four decades began her maiden
voyage in early September 1859 Brunel
himself was on the deck to witness what
should have been his greatest triumph
but as we've seen time and time again in
this video Brunel 's grandest projects
were always destined to end in some kind
of disaster still no one could have
predicted just how great a disaster
would accompany the Easterns launch
stood on the deck of his monster ship
that blustery day is some bad Kingdom
Brunel suffered a massive
stroke tom says seizure and collapsed
although he clung to life for another
few days his body who was really just
delaying the inevitable Brunel died on
September 15th 1859 it was 53 years old
in the wake of Brunel's death his
patrons in Bristol went on a fundraising
drive determined to build a suitable
monument in his honor that monuments
became the Clifton suspension bridge
finally finished burnell's original
designs in 1864 it would become the
engineers lasting legacy in the city but
what about the rest of the world at the
moment Brunel died he was considered a
great engineer but one who was plagued
by hubris who wasted his talents on
unworkable projects like the atmospheric
railway the Victorians actually
considered his father mark to have been
a better engineer despite his own flaws
against the guy who invented the tunnel
shield Brunel was just a mere dreamer
but I'm moved on and fashions changed as
the dour Victorian era gave way to the
20th century people began to realize
just how inspiring a dreamer can be
before long Brunel's maddest projects
came to be recognized not only as
failures but as heroic attempts to shape
the future today Brunel is not one
Victorian engineer among many he is the
Victorian engineer the man who was to
the steam age what da Vinci was to the
Renaissance while the truth is a little
more complicated there's no doubt that
Brunel deserves this reassessment he was
the child of a refugee father from a
family saddled with dare - nonetheless
managed to transform the face of Britain
making it into a modern industrial
powerhouse he may not have been the
father of the Industrial Revolution or
even its main contributor but his son
Bard Kingdom Brunel showed humanity what
it was capable of and he deserves his
place as one of the greatest Britons in
history so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below also if
you enjoyed this video please do check
out a new channel I'm working on called
business blaze it's sort of like this
but it's about business and it's a
little bit more laid back so if you
think you'll enjoy that I will link to
it below and thank you for watching
one epic middle name